des semaines de contre-offensive
ukrainienne des combats acharnés et une
armée russe à la peine en direct à la
télévision et le visage fermé le
ministre de la Défense ordonne le
repyrus de Carson région stratégique
conquise dès le début de la guerre
et assurer le transfert en toute
sécurité du personnel des armes et du
matériel à travers le fleuve Nièvre les
soldats russes ont Tordre de quitter la
rive nord du niepre notamment Kerson la
capitale régionale pour se retrancher
sur la Rive-Sud la ligne de France se
déplacerait donc de l'autre côté du
fleuve
car à l'appui le général Souro vikines
fraîchement nommé affirme que la
décision est difficile mais qu'il s'agit
de préserver la vie de ces hommes face à
la menace ukrainienne
ces dernières semaines sur ces images
diffusées sur les réseaux sociaux les
drapeaux russes avec commencer à
disparaître de certains bâtiments
officiels les autorités d'occupation
avaient évacuées des milliers de civils
la Russie accuse l'Ukraine de les
bombardés mais ce retrait s'il se
confirme apparaît bel et bien comme un
revers cinglant on est sur l'emblème le
plus important de ce qu'avait réussi à
faire la Russie depuis le début ils
n'ont pas réussi à prendre le café
évidemment ils n'ont pas réussi à
prendre tout le monde basse et là
c'était leur seul Capital régional
c'était une zone qui était
officiellement devenue la Russie du
point de vue russe donc là ils
abandonnent le territoire qui est
officiellement russe c'est vraiment une
catastrophe d'un point de vue
propagande le commandement russe évoque
des premières manœuvres rapides sans
indiquer s'il le retrait se compterait
en jour ou en semaine